nous avons retrouvé la liaison avec
béatrice mesa garcia professeur
chercheur africaniste à l'université
internationale de rabat on revient avec
vous sur ce sommet qui s'est tenu hier à
pau ce sommet organisé par emmanuel
macron et c'est lé président du g5 sahel
emmanuel macron et ses homonymes
africains ont donc défini hier un
nouveau cadre d'intervention à contrôler
état islamique contre le groupe etat
islamique dans le grand sahara est ce
que c'est un tournant profond ou bien il
est encore beaucoup trop tôt pour le
dire
on dira qu'on a fait les attentats se
multiplient et au ciel malgré la
présence internationale et malgré des
nouveaux mécanismes sécurité régionale
notamment lieu de cinq et l'afrique de
l'ouest il faut dire il faut gagner
aujourd'hui la guerre contre le
terrorisme mais pour gagner la guerre il
faut d'abord refonte et les a remis dans
le cas de mal il faut dire que l'armée a
été démantelé progressivement suite au
régime de modibo keïta en favorisant l
amie liz c'est à dire que les états ils
ont sous-estimé les armes et régionales
et au lieu de créer des armes est forte
collectionnez les états du sahel ont
vidé leurs propres armes et même et je
veux dire peu des soldats après ma
recherche ont limité leur action ou
celle de la caserne comme nous sortent
des réfugiés familiale non il n'y avait
pas si vous voulez un nombre de tripes
membres respectifs il n'y avait pas des
formations ni de la capacitation
milliards et sur chenilles aux
mentalités discipline militaire ou bien
on monte à l'it est des comptes joueurs
de force de la défense et de la sécurité
donc il faut dire que ces états de
celles qui sont en retard pour faire
face à des groupes insurgés qui
utilisent toujours de dg stratégie et
asymétrique donc on rêver non à cette
idée initiale et il faut croire aux
armées de manille pour ça pour cela il
faut fait monde et pas penser que l
aspect de l'argent au matériel est
fortement que parce que vous avez le
matériel dans son mauvaise opération des
5 face aux terroristes et les perdus et
donc il faut encore une fois de la
stratégie et militaires il faut
continuer son recourir
jours à la notion de l'ami lisent ce qui
étonnant que les pays occidentaux ne
savait depuis toujours que on se situe
des ventes d'un scénario qui est très
faible
c'est à dire les 5 pds 1 qui sont les
plus pauvres demande qui constitue déjà
remet très faibles donc il fallait
attendre 2012 pour réfléchir à ces défis
finalement certains nouvelle coalition
anti djihadistes telle qu'elle a été
annoncée hier par emmanuel macron et le
g5 et lé président du g5 sel est ce que
ce l'on voit elle sera suffisante pour
briser la dynamique des groupes armés
dans la région
bon il faut que ce soit suffisant
vous avez déjà entendu lien la
conférence de presse vérifiant un chef
d'état est même sous pression avec
française et moi je pense qu'il y a
language qui est inefficace qu'il faut
que par exemple des manière systématique
les pays mantoue faire face pour faire
fonctionner les armes et où vient pour
la livraison de matériel comment en
priorité par contre le vrai souci
aujourd'hui encore une fois ne se situe
pas dans l'aspect matériel
il y autre chose qui s'appelle la
mentalité le savoir-faire à la création
de forces est spécial la création de
force d'unité et d'action rapide
l'intelligence l'intelligence versus
informations le travail de
l'intelligence nécessite de temps encore
une fois le savoir-faire nécessite aussi
passer par des négociations veut la
scala d'aujourd'hui d'hostilité la
solution n'est pas comme il était arrivé
aussi de négociations qui peuvent
entamer qu'ils sont amis de la région
il faut travailler pour éviter les
recrutements des gens vers les cats et
des armées parce que la force
aujourd'hui la plupart mais des insurgés
c'est rose de la ressource oman se
trouve de la capri dans le capital man
règle août et pas forcément par à
vocation religieuse
il faut dire qu'il y à d'autres aspects
qui se mobilisent comme on réchauffe pas
remis et notre jeunesse ou sarel il
s'est par exemple la question 2
sur le pouvoir économique à côté vous
aussi et de la dignité aux le
nationalisme merci pour votre éclairage
béatrice mais à garcia professeur
chercheur africaniste à l'université
internationale de rabat